In the previous quiz, we saw that some of the requirements
that they put in the list were not pertinent. They were
irrelevant. So let me ask you. Why can irrelevant requirements be
harmful? Why is that a problem to have irrelevant requirements? So
here, I'm giving you four possible answers. And I'd like for
you to mark all that apply. Can irrelevant requirements be harmful
because they may lead to missing functionality in the final product.
Because they can introduce inconsistency. Because
they can waste the project resources.
Or because they may introduce bugs in the software system. And
as I said, more than one can be a valid reason.